you can reduce the file size of an image
by removing the number of bits you need
to represent each the colors and if you
remove that number of bits you have less
colors you can display so the image
looks worse if you've got eight bits
you've got 256 levels of gray or levels
of each color if you've got four bits
you've only got sixteen if you've got
one bit you've either got black or white
and so what did ring is it's doing is an
attempt to simulate those extra gray
scales let's keep it to a gray scales
for the purpose of this video just using
black and white pixels or whatever
colors you've got on the end for this
video we'll just keep it to either
having a black or a white pixel so quite
often computers certainly early screens
or even these days with printing they
can either display a pixel or they can't
display it they can either be black or
it can be white let's take this to the
extreme because it basically is the same
even if you have got more colors let's
assume that we've got a display that can
either display a black pixel or a white
pixel it might be a printer it might be
a sort of very very simple video display
of some sort particularly thought you
find on sale an early 80s computer
something although might be black and
green then but let's go black and white
and what we want to do is to be able to
display which is that a continuous tone
so they they don't just have black or
white we go from black through grays to
white and again you could extrapolate
this out to different colors and so you
need some way of mapping the grays into
black and white a naive way we could do
this we've got an image let's say it's a
photograph I say it's this video I'm
sure I'll apply the special effects to
make it look this and we need to convert
it to black and white as we can say
anything below a certain level will make
black anything above a certain level
will make white so we can do that and if
you do that
you can pick the level of which you make
that switch you get it with an effect
like this where you can sort of see it
Steve but realistically you've got lots
of white and lots of black that call for
a special effect but not useful for
watching or printing things so that's a
naive approach it's actually a problem
that's existed for years
newspapers are printing in general as
had this problems pretty much since
photography was invented in the 8th
hundreds and the way they get round it
is that they convert the image into a
series of dots actually this was
originally done optically the image that
they wanted to print was put in front of
a camera and a screen was put in front
of it of lots and lots of small things
and it was rephotographed with very high
contrast and what happened was whether
holes in the screen were you've got very
small pin pricks of light that depending
on how bright they were made bigger or
smaller discs on the photographic plate
and that's what was printed so we need
to do the same thing on our computer one
way to look at it if we wanted to say
make this square gray if you wanted to
make it black then we could just color
in all the pixels so can you have it as
white or black but we can also make it
appear grey just like the newspaper did
by not coloring all the squares inside
we can make it appear gray by coloring
in this one and then coloring in this
one like this and if you do that and you
do that for enough of them next to each
other
if you zoomed out from that then it
would look about 50% gray you could do a
lighter gray by just setting one pixel
of those four in each one and just to
finish off we could create a darker gray
by filling in all but one of the pixels
we can create just with a 2x2 grid of
pixels a white one a black one 50% gray
probably around 25% gray and around 75%
greater and get 1 2 3 4 5 different
levels of grey just by using a 2x2 grid
and selectively coloring in the pixels
what's actually happening is that your
eye is at acting like a sort of optical
low-pass filter and when it's slightly
fine of a way you stop seeing the
individual pixels and you just see the
sort of average gray from the number of
things that are in there you sort of
converting the high frequency off the
norms of the image into a grayscale
because you're looking at from a
distance and so on so that's what did
the ring effectively is it's choosing a
pattern of white and black dots to
create
the image to create the grey or to
simulate the gray that was a better way
of saying it now how do we do that in a
computer now if we think about an image
the image if we've sampled it it's
broken up into pixels and then they have
a number associated with it to say how
bright the artless is zero is black 255
is fully white so what we could do is
say well let's say they're 50% gray they
said they're all 50% gray so let's say
this is 128
this is 128 that's 128 that's 128 and so
on so how do i programmatically convert
that grid which is 50% gray into the
grid I've got here where I say okay I
want that one on I want that one off I
want that one on I want that one off so
we could do it by patter matter we could
look at this and say okay these four
pixels here or 128 therefore we need to
draw that pattern in it and these for 64
every 25% gray so we'll draw that
pattern the pixels in it you could do
like that but it's actually a clever way
you can actually do this let's draw out
a grid of the 4 by 4 here so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say if this
pixel is greater than 0 I will set it if
the value in the pixel is greater than
64 I will set that pixel if it is
greater than 1 to 8 I will set that
pixel and if it is greater than 1 9 2 I
will set that pixel okay so these are
each of our indifferent your pixels so
go back to my pixels here and I start
with this one is 128 greater than 64 yes
right so we color that in we're at my
level again here in math yes we now move
on to the next pixel is 128 greater than
hundred 28 no note that we leave that
there is 128 greater than that form all
there isn't a next one so we go back to
the beginning greater than 64 yes
we set that again and now we're going
across here is 128 greater than hundred
twenty-eight no so we leave that blank
so now we come down onto line two and we
do the same thing with the second line
here is 128 great at 192 no right ok we
leave it is
twenty-eight greater than zero yes okay
so we get the program to set this pixel
here is it greater than hundred
ninety-two nope is it greater than zero
yes and so we set that one there like
that and we're back here and we do the
same thing as a greater than twenty
eight and then no yes no no yes no and
what happens is that you end up creating
the pattern we'd come up here before
just by applying that thing there okay
let's try that again and we'll do it a
bit quicker this time let's say that
these are all 24 so what happens well we
do exactly the same thing we apply this
is 24 great in 64 no is 24 greater than
hundred twenty-eight no is 24 great in
64 no it's 24 greater than hundred
twenty-eight no is 24 greater than 192
no is 24 greater than zero
yes so we fill that in is 24 greater
than hundred ninety-two no zero yes and
now I shall go the same faster drew no
no no no yes no no yes and someone
created the pattern that we had for the
library a case come up in a different
position in that we had it in the top
left but let's come in here that was
like any difference to how it would look
to art it's just where the dots are
positioned and you say we've got
something that we can now apply
programmatically to create these five
different patterns to the image that we
can take our image run that overage and
create the same thing we get a nice fine
series of dots for the problem with this
is that we've only got five different
colors black dark gray mid gray light
gray white why don't we wanted more
colors well the way we could do that is
make this matrix bigger and use a number
of things but the problem with that is
if we do that we have to trade off the
resolution of our image because the dots
will become bigger to illustrate that
you're going to jump away from the paper
to my laptop because why I've done I
have created a little video which takes
the image from white to black so if we
play it this is gray scales that goes
from white
two black over the course of ten seconds
255 or 256 frames are then exported this
as a target image sequence relative poem
which applies the same algorithm but
this time using an 8x8 grid and because
I did it at low resolution we can
actually see the dots and so on so if we
play the same video this time it's
halftone we can see that the way it's
doing it is that the dots they're
getting bigger and bigger until
eventually you end up with a completely
black screen but whereas before when we
got to 50% gray we had relatively small
pixels there was one pixel arm one pixel
off we've now got four pixels on four
pixels off and bigger squares so we've
got dots that we can see just like the
dots in the newspaper we can actually
start to see the individual dots but we
still get that effect as if they're
getting the images getting darker as we
go through it and in fact if Shawn were
to sort of point is camera at it that
should if you gets it out of focus you
know if the camera will act as a
low-pass filter and you should see it go
from like white to dark gray but it is
still a collection of dots next to each
other so that's one way that we can
dither an image we can sort of apply a
regular pattern and ordered patterns as
an order did they recall this to the
image and convert the individual pixels
into black and white dots to create the
gray scales we can either say it to be
white 255 or black zero so we choose the
one which is closer so in this case the
closest one we could leave it as white